speaking of Biden family controversies
Hunters attorneys wrote a scathing
screed to house Ways and Means chairman
Jason Smith attacking the IRS
whistleblowers and in it they claim
whistleblower Gary shapley leaked
details of the investigation to The
Washington Post article back in October
the article detailed how federal agents
believed they had sufficient evidence to
charge hunter that Hunter's attorneys
described this as an illegal Leak with
no evidence mind you that shapley was
the source of the leak that's what they
allege anyway shackley's lawyers are
fighting back sending a letter to the
Washington Post demanding that they set
the record straight on allegedly false
and defamatory statements made by
Hunter's legal team and intimidation has
become the go-to plan for the Hunter's
team as Kim strassel of the Wall Street
Journal notes quote Hunter Biden has
adopted a legal strategy of threats and
character assassination the real targets
of Hunter lawyer Hunter's lawyer lawyers
were the whistleblowers themselves and
the letter is filled with inaccuracy and
innuendo so joining me now to discuss
more of this in the details is Jason
Foster the attorney for IRS Reservoir
Gary shapley so Jason you know Fox
digital reached out on Wednesday to a
representative for the Washington Post
asking them you know why are you
accusing your your client of being this
source of what they say is an illegal
leak and they don't want to comment on
their sourcing so what's your next
course of action if they won't admit
that your client isn't the leaker
well I mean we've already taken decisive
action by sending an affidavit to the
Ways and Means Committee in which Gary
swears that it wasn't him under a
penalty of 1001 false statements to
Congress he could be prosecuted if he's
lying about that and we've challenged
The Washington Post we've released them
if you if they want to release any
Communications directly or indirectly
with Gary and anyone at the Washington
Post they are free to do so
um to but they're not going to do that
because they want to hide behind the
statement well we don't comment on
sourcing you know I understand that I
understand why they don't want to
comment on sourcing they don't want to
start a game of process of elimination
and asking and answering questions about
who the sources are for their for their
pieces but this is a unique situation
because the Washington Post uniquely
among all media knows
the truth that what Abby Lowell wrote is
a lie
so in in terms of of what the Washington
Post is refusing to do here essentially
they're helping the Biden team the
hunter Biden team intimidate your client
by not
saying that he's not the leaker I mean
you've argued this is defamation
exactly I mean they're they're
essentially but their silence makes them
complicit in a plan by the Biden legal
team to
um to plant you know this retaliatory
accusation against uh folks who are
blowing the whistle on
um on the you know special treatment
that was given to the president's son in
a criminal investigation and anyone who
works with whistleblowers and for and on
behalf of whistleblowers for any period
of time recognizes this this is a common
pattern this is what always happens
every single time yeah when
whistleblowers come forward with
evidence supporting their information
and it causes pain for people in power
they lash out at The Whistleblower they
try to make the Whistleblower the issue
instead of the issue that The
Whistleblower is blowing the whistle on
and here we have Gary shapley and you
know you know his credibility really
doesn't even matter because he is break
he's brought documents and evidence and
the inspectors gen General at the
justice department and for the IRS we'll
be able to get mountains more of
evidence because what he's saying is
true and there will be tons of
corroborating evidence to back it up so
it doesn't really matter what Gary
shapley's credibility is what he said is
accurate there were punches pulled on
the hunter Biden investigation and now
Hunter Biden's lawyers are trying to Gin
up some kind of a criminal inquiry
against the person who blew the whistle
on on that preferential treatment well
and Mr shapley's claims have been
corroborated by other whistleblowers as
well so his credibility is has certainly
been bolstered by other people who have
similar information about what went on
here but in terms of the legality here I
mean it is illegal for retaliation
against someone who is a whistleblower
who has protections from Congress for
the whoever they're working for to lash
out against them but it seems like a
tactic that the hunter Biden lawyers are
using in a roundabout way to go after
someone who is legally protected as a
whistleblower through that process and
it's not that your clients just working
with Republicans you're also working
with Democrats in the Senate to get to
the bottom of what happened here
that's absolutely right and it was and
it was Gary shapley's insistence from
the very beginning that he would make he
want he's not afraid of being
cross-examined by both sides he wants to
be cross-examined by both sides he he
insisted that this be a bipartisan
process and that's what we've done and
even before going to Congress you know
he went to the the doj Inspector General
and they have been investigating this
for some time before even any of this
went public so and you can see that the
reason that they're doing this is just
to distract to make Gary the issue
instead of you know dealing with
um the issues that you know they're on
their heels now I mean Mr Weiss the U.S
attorney in Delaware you know recently
sent a letter up to Capitol Hill that
you know essentially changed his tune
and and practically admits everything
that Gary has been saying that letter
that he sent up you know he basically
says yeah I can't charge outside of
Delaware that's exactly what Gary said I
needed permission of the U.S attorneys
in in DC or California
and that's that's the problem that Gary
was blowing the whistle on there's no
reason that President Biden's political
appointees in those districts should
have had any role anywhere near this
investigation of the president's son and
they did it they did and there was a
sweetheart deal that was cut and we'll
see where that goes from here certainly
there's a lot to unpack and we look
forward to what your client has to say
in the future thank you so much Jason
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else